[Music]
I want a big wedding you know you think
the Royals did it
mega marketing I have nothing on this
event yes
[Music]
are you a groomzilla um yes I want to
say yes because I have been planning
this wedding before I even got engaged
but I'm a groomzilla because I want we
want to have a good time so the event is
really not about me it's about my
partner about my kids our families our
friends I want them to say wow this was
the best time we ever had to connect let
loose and just enjoy ourselves speaking
of that wedding planning how's it going
do we have a date yes I do have a date I
can't tell the date last time I told the
date he got mad at me but trust and
believe it's going to be big I will tell
you this we rented out the Merv
Griffin's estate in Palm Springs
it's like 3,300 acres it's like a really
really big so yeah it's beautiful so
we're excited about that what time of
year are you guys thinking for the
wedding definitely going to be in the
fall because I think there's something
about a fall wedding the leaves are
changing there's something about change
and going into new growth that I was
really special to me and also the date
means a lot now that guest list I gotta
know have you guys narrowed it down
who's on the guest list I'm thinking the
fab 5 right yes yes the other guys are
definitely on the the guest list it's
funny because Jonathan keeps telling me
I said do you want to be my best man
he's like no I want to be your ring
bearer
they're your little ring girl and I'm
like okay honey you could be my ring
girl yeah whatever you want but we we
are narrowing it down now someone you've
spoken about that has really inspired
you or inspired you to come out with
RuPaul is he getting an invite to the
wedding listen
RuPaul we have never met you have
influenced me since I was 12 years old
and you had your talk show back in the
day on vh1 I would love for you to join
me at my wedding
listen I want you right next to me I
will kick my best friend out of the way
if RuPaul wants to stand next to me as
my best man just an invitation probably
will never see this but if he does he
will see this and you are cordially
invited to the best wedding of the year
yes yeah you are
[Music]